vous êtes le frère d'hervé première
victime de décapitation en france votre
frère vie chère d'entreprise a été tué
sur son lieu de travail une usine à
saint quentin fallavier en isère par
l'un de ses employés ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter ce qui s'est passé pour
hervé le 26 juin 2015
votre frère sans salarié a été dans son
entreprise tôt le matin et ensuite il a
prétendu une panne dans un camion pour
que son employeur et canards à s'y
déplace il l'a fait venir dans le camion
il l'a étranglée par l'arrière après
l'avoir tué
il a pris le camion il est parti il
s'est arrêté sur ton chemin
il a décapité mon frère il a utilisé sa
tête comme en a trop fait persuadé
selphy les envoyer à ses amis
et puis il a été sur une usine seveso il
a essayé de il a accroché la tête de mon
frère sur un grillage avec ces drapeaux
pour pour faire ses affaires et ensuite
il a essayé de faire sauter l'usiné
seveso
mais savait pas utiliser les manettes
dans le camion pour mélanger les gaz et
finalement il a juste fait sauter le
camion ou la boule et le camion mais là
pas réussi à faire sauter leur usine
donc il s'est jeté sur les bouteilles de
gaz qu'ils étaient dans les usines mais
la sécurité il a tout de suite arrêté
voilà ce à quoi ils et pourquoi at il
été tué votre vapo pourquoi il a tué
votre frère cet employé c'était quoi ces
phares était président d'une association
des locataires des marronniers là où il
habitait il défend des les personnes qui
vivaient il essayait de leur à manger
lors leur vie pour que ce soit plus
agréable la plus confortable dans la
cité ils s'intéressaient pas la religion
il avait des usines de transport il
avait une société transport et donner du
travail à plein de petit livreur du
quartier qui était musulman aussi donc
il y avait aucune raison d'attaquer à
lui si ce n'est vous la faire sauter la
ville de lyon parce que si réellement il
avait réussi à mélanger les gaz comme il
le fallait parce que la ville de lyon
n'existerait pas aujourd'hui ou en tout
cas ce récit en avait reçu des menaces
votre frère à ce qu'il avait dit quelque
chose qui est ce qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose pourquoi pourquoi il s'est
attaqué à lui je sais pas je sais n'a
jamais su et plus en fait pas maintenant
on a su par la suite que ce gas in il
parti en syrie s'entraîner il avait
plusieurs passeports que l épisode le
djihad qu'il était revenu pour pouvoir
faire son djihad en france ça on a su
après pourquoi s'il a voulu tuer avait
peut-être pour prouver à d'autres
personnes que lui aussi vous avez le
jihad en france et qu'il était capable
de décapiter une personne est ce qu'il a
fait en tout cas il n'a pas décapité mon
frère hervé parce que mon frère avait
place fait mais parce que mon frère
avait utilisé un propose une raison mais
voilà ces annonces étaient vraiment pas
c'était pour autre chose alors et en
faisait du bien même oui bah oui tarbes
et faisait du bien ah oui là aujourd'hui
si les gens est en colère service est
déjà remis aujourd'hui je sais que vous
êtes en colère puisque c'est cette
affaire elle a eu lieu il ya cinq ans
maintenant
qu'est ce qui a été fait depuis cinq ans
pour vous en fait c'est ça faire en fait
je voudrais expliquer ma colère pour que
les gens comprennent qu agent de colère
j'ai déjà c'est pas de la déception ça
c'est pas de la déception comme perrette
et le pot tollet vous savez c'est pas du
tout ça c'est une colère qui est nourri
par des choses qui sont arrivées lorsque
mon frère était décapité c'était
vraiment très difficile et très violent
comme nouvelle à croire c'était vraiment
terrible c'était la première fois que ça
arrivait en france est généralement
depuis 20 souvent on entendait les
décapitations mais sur les lieux de
guerre là où c'était la guerre les ans
tu es mais pas en france ailleurs et là
pour la première fois c'était en france
et donc ça a été un choc vraiment un
choc d'une violence inouïe
donc les premiers jours on était
traumatisée les gens sont venus nous
parler mais on savait vraiment pas ce
qu'il se passait vraiment et je pense
qu'il m'a fallu moment deux à deux
belles années pour arriver à remettre
les pieds sur terre et pour arriver à
réaliser que oui c'était la vérité oui
c'était bien en france alors on a eu des
gens qui sont venues de tous bords
politiques pour nous parler pour nous
réconforter pour nous dire que les bains
il ne laisserait pas faire
on a eu le ministre de l'intérieur qui a
fait un discours en expliquant que
jamais ils oublieraient la famille
camara que jamais il laisserait faire
des choses terribles encore se passer
ils ont dit aussi qu il avait le devoir
de mémoire
ils ont dit aussi que il voudrait
riposté que n'allait pas laisser faire
et en fait je me suis fait à l'idée que
ça laisse passer qu'ils allaient vent
s'occuper de nous et puis rien n'a été
fait quand j'ai entendu la télévision
qui a eu une personne qui a été décapité
la botte d'abord été dit qu'il avait été
décapité et pas que c'est un terroriste
mais moi dans ma tête
en fait je m'étais protégée depuis
depuis deux trois ans pour éviter de
regarder les choses qui me déplaisait
qui me ramenait des souvenirs négatifs
sur l'assassinât de mon frère ma famille
faisait pareil ma mère faisait pareil et
en fait je pensais que j'étais protégé à
l'intérieur de moi même de ce qui
pouvait arriver et que je pourrais
arriver à vivre la vie comme les autres
mais en fait quand j'ai entendu ça ça a
réveillé en moi un dragon oui comme
l'énergie où je me suis dit c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible
ils vont pas le refaire et donc on se
dit mais alors qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
qu'est ce qui a été fait depuis
longtemps les promesses qui ont été
faites que il n'allait pas laisser les
choses se faire comme ça cinq ans après
votre colère ah oui alors c'est de
l'amertume c'est de la colère c'est de
l'incompréhension et j'ai rien en fait
persie rien de personnel contre le
ministre de l'intérieur pas dû à
l'époque en 2015 péquiste et cadenassent
9 c'était bien lui j'ai rien contre lui
mais contre sa fonction et ce qu'il a
fait le bilan
je trouve que c'est vraiment je
comprends tout à fait ce que des billets
parce que je me tourne vers mounir venir
on a vraiment l'impression et je pense
que tout le monde ça fera l'unanimité
ici que après un jour 2 jours 3 jours on
a l'impression que les gouvernements qui
succède sont vraiment à fond et disent
on va faire beaucoup de choses on va
faire si on va faire ça et qui est déjà
des semaines qui se passent des mois et
puis après on n'oublie rien ne se passe
et on attend le prochain drame c'est un
petit peu ce que dit didier voilà les
gouvernements succèdent et on voit que
les choses ne rien n'avance pas alors on
a vu darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur
là qui à bouger dans tous les sens cette
semaine
voilà il est il a ajouté un petit peu
partout même dessin soit un conte
comprenais pas
voilà alors les rings héroïsme
reconnaître médias parce que la colère
10e la comprendre et c'est la colère de
plein de gens ont dit qu'ils se disent
voilà là où on a l'impression qu'ils
sont sur la bête qui sont sur le coup
qui sont sûres voilà qui sont sur le
dossier mais tu en voilà l'émotion tant
qu'ils sont encore voilà dans l'émotion
et quand l'émotion va passer eh bien on
va dire bon bah ça y est l'émotion est
passée on passe à autre chose
donc comment on fait pour s'assurer que
ce qu'on raconte aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment un engagement sur le long terme
sur une transformation véritable de deux
noeuds perception et nous tous là les
français de l'état qui prend les
décisions et des gouverneurs jeudi après
le décès des décisions qui sont vraiment
pris ce que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
on parlait du ministre de la justice qui
disait qu'il n'y aurait plus d'anonymat
monsieur sur les voiles à lille 1 2 puis
10 un souhait mais les souhaits et les
minutes pour le faire jusqu'au bout sous
le pouvoir est dans les détails de tous
les moyens lui manoeuvre dans le détail
des sujets ya le sujet renseignements ya
le sujet militaire faut le dire une
chose cette guerre elle est mondiale et
donc il faut qu'on intervienne depuis
2015 est-ce qu'on est intervenu le
maximum possible contre tous les
terroristes dans le monde on est en
soutien ou parfois en tête de ses
opérations sur le renseignement
et ce qui est assez d'agents à chaque
nouveau drame qui apparaît on voit les
limitations
donc on fait mieux on fait plus mais on
n'a jamais autant recruter des agents de
renseignement que ce soit survenu le
tour national théâtre traditionnel que
ces dernières années mais
malheureusement les a pas attraper donc
c'est que ça va pas les erreurs qu'ils
étaient prêts à van avant votre arrivée
particulier sur la question des français
qui ont combattu en séries après les
attentats de charlie d'hyper cacher de
2002 2015
les services secrets syriens qui donc
bachar al assad inquiète sont des
ennemis de la france ont proposé à la
france en l'occurrence à manuel valls de
donner la liste des français des
jihadistes français en série et manuel
valls et c'est bernard squarcini qui le
raconte à refuser cette liste par
obstination politicienne en disant
puisque je suis fâché avec bachar al
assad
je peux même pas maintenir une espèce de
sucre uc opérationnel en dessous qui
m'aiderait il ya eu un tas et on a
cumulé les erreurs graves ici au
permettez si vous permettez choses à
dire j'ai vraiment des choses à dire
excusez moi tout ski sur le domaine
international
ok c'est bien mais pour nous famille
camara c'est du pipeau on part donc
pardon je pensais que j'allais dire mais
ça vous dirait un curé
j'aurais juste dire une chose à l'époque
de mon frère on n'arrêtait pas dire il
faut empêcher les jeunes de partir en
syrie pour aller s'entraîner parce
qu'ils vont se radicaliser
ah bon ils sont pas partis mais qu'est
ce qui s'est passé avec le pitch etienne
il n'est pas parti en syrie
donc c'est pourtant ici radicaliser donc
ça sert à quoi
voyez ce genre de questions nous l'avait
vu qu'on avance la pause et depuis cinq
ans que ce mon frère a été décapitée
jusqu'à la semaine dernière où un autre
français a été décapité
moi j'ai l'impression que le
gouvernement il est un petit peu comme
une ménagère qui passe aspirateur est
derrière et en a qui mangent des
biscottes et salissent de partout et
donc le gouvernement il se dit eh ben on
va changer l'aspirateur en en mettant
plus puissant 8
moi je dis non il faut soit retiré les
biscottes soit empêché les gens de
manger mais monsieur échanges et
respirateurs si elle va pas changer
grand chose vous avez les terroristes en
général y meurent dans les attentats les
musulmans français ou français musulmans
n'y sont pour rien dans ces attentats
et on parle on va vous mettre d'accord
sur une chose peut-être tout ce soir on
parle d'un petit nombre de gens qu'on
appelle ici la zone de porosité ou la
zone grise qui font que moi je me
souviens que dans les 110 80 j'étais
élève il y avait aucun problème ni avec
les juifs réclusion on avait à l'école
personnes se poser la question
meilleurs amis s'appellent kamel nejjar
je le salue ce soir on allait encore en
cours ensemble tous les jours on faisait
jamais allusion faite qu'on était
musulman juif mais aucune jamais passer
devant l'église ont passé trop de liens
ici non mais j'arrivais au fait si
aujourd'hui un problème c'est qu'à cette
zone et qui est une zone qui est à la
fois passive et active une zone perverse
lime en anglais une zone de glu qui
permet le collage entre des petits mecs
qui savent pas se structurer parce
qu'ils vont pas à l'école ils n'ont pas
envie d'y aller et cette zone qui ont
exporté à la fois sur internet et dans
les pays en guerre comme la syrie et si
vous laissez cette zone qui arrive à
faire le plein de musulmans tranquille
en lait en les poussant
imperceptiblement de manière graduelle
mais mettrait à venir et fatiha les
flériens il est là aussi on pourra un
peu positive adoré générique aucune
tendresse avec macro et son gouvernement
on apprend c'est pourquoi parce qu'on a
un état de droit notre réflexe et l'état
de droit notre réflexe nous sépare on
nous a dit comment protéger les profs on
veut pas policiers dans nos classes on
n'en veut pas d'état de droit de nos
élèves on est bien en classe je voudrais
dire c'est que des efforts ont été faits
on apprend des choses on s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait des carences
structurelles
bernard cazeneuve qui ont été promises
il n'a pas été très excellent par contre
maintenant il dit qu'il faut il joue le
matin mais on s'est rendu compte que le
niveau d'arabe de gens qui étaient
censés espionner ceux qui parlent en
arabe et est nullissime
voilà on apprend c'est fastidieux ce qui
est terrible c'est que ça se traduit par
des morts voilà on refait
téléspectateurs à notre question se
soient professeurs des capitaux répond
aux torts et ont pu l'éviter oui à 79%
non à 21%
le coran pour les nuls c'est tareq
oubrou qui est avec nous recteur et
grand imam de bordeaux
je voulais c'est le mot de la fin didier
houi vous dire quelque chose
j'ai plein de choses à dire mais en
louangeant dire une seule j'ai vu madame
taubira je demande à madame taubira
pourquoi emilie de la justice et elle
mérite de laisser ça à l'époque et je le
demandais pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas
à garder mon frère que ce monsieur était
un terroriste était dangereux et qui
conduisait un camion de l'équipe
dangereux jusqu'à aujourd'hui
elle ne m'a jamais répondu vous n'avez
jamais eu de réponse ils étaient fichés
a été fiché
ah ouais il s'en méfie chaise jamais
aucune réponse c est ce que je voudrais
dire aussi c'est que lorsqu'on a bu un
tout petit peu trop d'alcool un tout
petit peu trop de bière ou peu importe
on n'a pas droit de conduire
c'est interdit alors pourquoi les
fichiers s il en droit de conduire des
camions des transports publics des bus
des camions qui porte encore des
liquides dangereux pourquoi aussi à bord
aussi oui oui
répondez moi parce que je voudrais
vraiment le savoir je comprends pas
répondre à cette dernière question vous
dire qui est intéressant déjà moi je
donne lorsque vous exprimer il ya eu 90
et qu'on doit tous aussi faire le
silence et loire deux autres frères et
c'est très important
vous dites qu'est ce qu'on fait de ces
fichiers est ce c'est un sujet qu'on
n'abordait à plusieurs reprises ce soir
et fish est ce dont on sait qu'il ya un
risque majeur c'est vrai qu'on a voté
une loi qui s'est fait retoquer en
partie par le conseil constitutionnel il
ya quelques semaines pour ceux qui
sortent de prison et dont on sait qu'ils
étaient radicalisant prison dont on sait
qu'ils représentent un risque mais dont
la peine est terminée donc on va pas
pouvoir les laisser dans la nature on
doit les laisser sortir ils nous on a
voté une loi pour dire qu'il va falloir
qu'on puisse les contrôler plus en plus
les convoquer plus régulièrement comme
il serait qu'on puisse plus
régulièrement à voir ce qu'on ne fait
pas sur d'autres sites web est sûre on
le ferait parce qu'il représente un
risque majeur est ce que les employeurs
seront prévenus c'est notre volonté
désigner les regards seront prévenus que
sur dans les personnes les plus à risque
on puisse mettre plus de moyens et le
faire les maires ne le sont pas arrêtés
notamment sur des ça le problème mes
rations désert s'il avait su il faut la
justice ce qui est très grave danser
dans ces meurtres quand les cdc
terroriste meurent avant d'être jugé
c'est qu'on n'a pas cet événement qui
est très important pour tous et la
justice public malheureusement le
meurtrier de notre ère il sera pas jugé
il y aura il y aura une sanction morale
et charlie à trois procès en ce moment
même en voilà un chantier a
malheureusement nous n'avons pas les
valeurs devant nous et ça ça fait du mal
et donc il faut qu'on soit grave de
rendre justice aussi pour leur mémoire